Cheers ran from 1982 to 1993 and was one
of the biggest critical and ratings
success stories of its era Emmy voters
nominated it for Outstanding Comedy
Series in all eleven of its seasons and
cheers ultimately 128 enemies against
179 total nominations more than 40
million households watched the show's
finale still the show's most impressive
accomplishment might be the way it stars
defied typecasting and have continued to
work in Hollywood but while you've
certainly seen them over the years you
might not recognize the cheers cast
today Ted Danson Sam Malone
after Sam Malone turned out the lights
on Cheers Ted Danson made guest
appearances as a Malone on Frasier and
The Simpsons but went on to compete with
Woody Harrelson for the most diverse
career among former cast members he
played himself in 13 episodes of Curb
Your Enthusiasm starting the sitcom
Becker for six seasons got another Emmy
nod for his ruthless CEO character on
damages and appeared on CSI cyber as d-v
Russell a character he originated on CSI
through all that he's also popped up in
numerous other film and television roles
and has been married to Mary Steenburgen
since 1995 well he doesn't exactly look
like bar owner Sam Malone anymore you
can catch Danson on NBC's the good plays
in season two of FX's Fargo Shelley Long
Diane chambers for five years Diane
chambers of Bennington College graduate
one and everyone to know she was smarter
than her cocktail waitress job would
indicate but before season six
Shelley long left cheers to pursue other
work and spend more time with her family
if I go I am never ever coming back she
went on to appear in several movies and
TV shows including the money pit The
Brady Bunch movie true Beverly Hills and
later even revived Diane for an episode
of Frasier she's also been seen
occasionally on Modern Family playing
Dede Pritchett Christie Ally Rebecca
Howe after replacing Shelly long and
cheers as the new object of Sam Malone's
affection Kirstie Alley went on to star
in Veronica's closet for three seasons
and then the look who's talking movies
with John Travolta her pseudo reality
series fat actress outlined her public
struggles with her weight
more recently she starred in one season
on her TV Land sitcom Kirstie
guest-starred on the Netflix series
flaked and been a fan favorite on season
15 of Dancing with the Stars John
Ratzenberger
Clavin according to his website John
Ratzenberger originally read the role of
norm but since he wouldn't get it and
suggest that cheers should have a
know-it-all character at the bar
the producers agreed so they created
cliff Clavin to drop some knowledge on
us by my calculations next president has
to be named yel Nick and Wawa well he
still works consistently as a character
actor Brad some burgers face isn't on
camera as much as his former castmates
you've certainly heard him though he's
hand the piggy bank in the Toy Story
movies and he's the only voice actor to
appear in every Pixar film I'll have you
know tampered with the male is a crime
punishable by banishment George Wendt
norm Peterson once acting resume since
leading norm on the barstool of Cheers
is longer than a master mixologist drink
menu in addition to his ill-fated sitcom
the George Wendt show he's appeared in
everything from Michael Jackson's black
or white video to Saturday Night Live's
recurring to bear sketch to comedy nerd
favorites like Children's Hospital and
Portlandia Rhea Perlman Carla Tortelli
after winning four Emmy Awards for
playing cheers brash cocktail waitress
Rhea Perlman has worked consistently
since the show ended she's regularly
guest-starred on television shows
including the Mindy project and has
appeared in several movies including
there goes the neighborhood
Sunset Park and Mathilda the last of
which co-starred her husband Danny
DeVito Woody Harrelson woody Boyd the
part of woody a small-town hayseed
trying to make it in Boston earned woody
harrelson five Emmy nominations one win
and made him a star he rode his cheers
Fame into diverse roles in blockbuster
movies like white men can't jump
Indecent Proposal Natural Born Killers
Zombieland the People vs Larry Flynt and
the messenger the latter two of which
earned an Oscar nominations since then
he starred in HBO's first season of True
detective and the Hunger Games films
Kelsey Grammer dr. Frasier Crane
producers originally hired Kelsey
Grammer to appeared in a six episode arc
but fans loved Frasier so much the
Grammer went on to portray the stuffy
doctor for two decades
Frasier became one of the most popular
TV spin-offs of all time running for 11
seasons and winning 37 Emmy Awards
one hundred and eight nominations
Grammer has appeared often on Broadway
since Fraser ended has made multiple
guest appearances on TV shows like 30
rock starred in four more TV series that
haven't been as successful including
Boston Hank and became another TV
mainstay a Sideshow Bob on The Simpsons
and if that wasn't enough there was also
the time this happened trip through it's
a small world pretending I was a UN
interpreter thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which cheers cast member is your
favorite